i've talked a lot about the general idea
that in order to have a state variable
like say
u which is internal energy at any point
in this pv diagram that state variable
should be that value so for example if
at this point u is equal to five and i
go do this whole carnot cycle when i
come back to state a u should still be
equal to five it should not have changed
it's not dependent upon what we did to
get there so if we did some kind of
crazy uh path on our on our pv diagram
we got back there u should always be the
same that's what it means to be a state
variable it's only dependent upon its
position in this pv diagram it's only
dependent on its state not how you got
there and because of that heat is
something that we can't really use as a
state variable for example if i tried to
define some heat
some heat related state variable let's
say i call it heat content
and i defined change in heat content is
equal to
the amount of heat added to the system
well if we go back to our carnot cycle
here let's say my heat content here was
was 10. well i added some heat here in
this in this state in this process here
nothing happened because this was
adiabatic from b to c then from c to d i
took out some heat but i took out less
heat than i was added here and then here
nothing was done with regard to heat so
i did add some heat to the system the
net heat that i added to the system as i
went around the cycle in this case q
would be equal to q1
minus q2
and we know that this this number is
larger than this the net amount of heat
we added to the system was the amount of
work we did on the system because the
internal energy didn't change so if the
internal if this is zero if this right
here is zero
then the amount of the amount of heat we
add to the system is the amount of work
we did our internal energy is definitely
zero as we go all the way around we did
this shaded portion of work i showed you
that several videos ago that the area
inside of our of our little cycle is the
amount of work we did and so that's also
the net amount of heat added to the
system
so if we added that amount of heat to
the system if we started off at a heat
of 10 here or whatever my heat content
mystical variable i made up just now
when we go around it would then be 10
plus w we go around again it would be 10
plus 2w and 10 plus 3w so it stay it
can't be a legitimate state variable
because it's completely dependent on
what we did to get there and if we keep
going around the cycle we can increase
it even though we get to the same point
so this is an illegitimate state
variable where i define the change in
our little made up heat content to be
equal to the heat added to system not a
valid state variable ignore it all
now
we know that q1 we added more heat here
than we took away so there was some net
heat added but then we can maybe you
know there's something interesting here
we added it from a at a higher
temperature and here we took less heat
away at a lower temperature so maybe we
can define another
another state variable that can have the
result that when we go around the cycle
we do get back to our same value
and let me just we're just experimenting
although i know where this experiment
will go i wouldn't have been doing it if
i didn't so let's say i define a new
state variable s and i define a chain
and a change in s
so i say a change in s i'm just making
up a definition is equal to
the heat added to the system divided by
the temperature at which it was added to
the system now i don't know what this
means just yet in future videos maybe
we'll get an intuition about what this
actually means
in kind of our minds but let's see if at
least at least this is a valid state
variable if as we go around the carnot
cycle whether our change in delta s is
zero right to be a legitimate state
variable we have some value for s here
maybe it's a hundred i don't know
once we go back around the carnot cycle
it should be a hundred again or a delta
s should be zero
so what's the delta s
so the delta s as we go around the whole
cycle let me write delta s
we do another color
delta s
as we go around i'll say c for the
carnot cycle as we go around the carnot
cycle is going to be equal to well when
we went from a to b
we were at a constant temperature and we
added q1 so it's q1
and we're at temperature t1 fair enough
then when we went from b to c it was
adiabatic we added or took away no heat
so this value q over t would just be
zero so it's plus zero
then we went from c to d that we were at
a new temperature we were on a new
isoterm we were at t2
and we took away or i won't put the sign
here let's just say we added q2 heat
we're going to actually solve for it
later we added q2 heat we'll see that
it's actually a negative value and then
finally when we went
from d
to a it was adiabatic again so no
transfer of heat
so plus zero right these zeros are zeros
over you know changing temperature but
it's just zero
so this thing should be equal to zero in
order for this to be a valid state
variable so let's figure out what this
value is what q1 so our change in
our change in our mystical new candidate
state variable s is as we go around the
carnot cycle is equal to q1 over t1 plus
q2
over
t2 we'll see q2 is negative
so what is the amount of
what is q1 can we calculate eq1
well as we go as we're on this top
isotherm our temperature doesn't change
our internal energy doesn't change
so if your internal energy does not
change if your internal energy is zero
then the heat added to the system is
equal to the work done by the system so
it's the area under this curve
it's the area under this curve not just
the area in the cycle it'd be the whole
area under the curve
so what's the whole area under the curve
well
so let me do a little aside here so q1
q1 is equal to the work done is we went
from a to b and work remember can just
be written as
pressure
pressure times change in volume we're
going to do a little calculus here so
i'll write dv for a small change in
volume
for a small change in volume and we're
going to integrate it all over the
little sums right this
this dv is this little change in volume
right there times pressure that makes a
little rectangle and then we sum up all
the rectangles
so we sum up all of the rectangles from
our initial volume which is va
to our final volume which is v
b
and then what's q 2 going to be equal to
well q 2
is going to be essentially the same
thing
it's going to be the sum of our pressure
of the work done by our system which in
this case is going to be negative
because work was done to our system as
we go from here to here right that's
when q2 was operating
was the heat was being taken out of the
system so we're going to go from
we're going to go from where was our
starting point v c
and we go to
v
v d now how can we evaluate these
integrals well we do we've done this
before in a previous video we use the
fact both in q both of these
circumstances when we go to a to b and
when we go from c to d
both of these circumstances occur on
isotherms
right
so the only things that are changing are
pressure and volume temperature is not
changing
and so if we go back to our ideal gas
equation
that pv
is equal to
nrt we can just rewrite this by dividing
both sides by v as p
is equal to n
r
t
over v
and use and substitute that back in for
p in both cases that is p as a function
of v we now have the equation of the
curve and we're taking the area under it
in both cases
so q 1
is equal to the integral from v a
to v
b
of
n r t
over v d v
and q two
is equal to the integral
from v c
to v
d
of n r t over v
dv i'm going to do two two integrals in
parallel
just so that you kind of see that we're
essentially solving the same thing
okay so how can we solve this
well we know in both of these cases
we're moving along an isotherm that our
temperature our temperatures are
constant and actually we know what the
temperatures are on that when we're
moving from va to vb our temperature is
t1 it was kept that way by our reservoir
when we moved from vc to vd our
temperature was t2 it was kept that way
by our reservoir right t2 when we move
from c to d
and t1 we move from a to b those are our
temperatures and they're constant
fair enough so let's we can take so n is
constant r is definitely a constant
n is just the number of molecules we
have and then our temperature is also
constant so we can take it out of the
integral
so we can rewrite
q one is equal to n r
t one
over
the integral from va
to vb
times 1 over v
dv
and q2 we can write as
nrt2 times the integral from vc
to vd
1 over v
dv
all right now this integral is fairly
straightforward to evaluate the
anti-derivative of 1 over v is the
natural log of v
so we get q1
is equal to nrt1
times the natural log of v evaluated at
vb
minus it evaluated at va
and
q2 let me just solve this whole equation
right here so this is equal to what this
is equal to the natural log of vb minus
the natural log of va which is the same
thing
as the natural log of vb
over va
times n
r t 1 and all that's equal to q 1.
now the same logic q 2 is going to be
equal to what
q 2
is going to be equal to n
r t 2
now the only difference with this
integral is where i had v b now i have v
d
sorry
so now then it becomes natural log of v
d and where i had v a now i have v c so
over v c
all right now what was our original
question that we were dealing with we
said this is a legitimate state variable
if our totals if this if the change in
this whatever this value s as we go
around the cycle is equal to zero that
means it didn't change
so these two things when you sum them
have to equal zero q1 over t1 plus q2
over t2 so let's add them
so q1 over t1 so q1 over t1 is equal to
that over t1
that cancels out q2 over t2 is equal to
that over t2
that cancels out
so
q our change in our mystical state
variable as we go around the carnot
cycle is equal to q1 over t1
plus q2 over t2 which is equal to
nr
n
r times the natural log of vb
over va that's that right there
and then plus
q2 over t2 which is just
n
r times
the natural log of v d over v a this is
sorry over v
over v c
this is v c this is a v a here
all right now let's see what we can do
this is equal to
almost there home stretch
nr we can factor out an nr
and then the natural log of a plus the
natural log of b is just the same thing
as the natural log of a b so this is
equal times the natural log
of v b
over v
v a
times
v d
over v c
all right
now this is so this is our change in our
s
state variable that we're playing with
right now now what does this equal to
now what if we divide the numerator and
then or let's say we multiply
let me think of the best way to to say
this so let's let's divide the numerator
and the denominator by v c so let me
take this expression here and divide
its numerator and its denominator
essentially by
by v c over v d or let me multiply its
numerator and denominator by v c over v
d so i can rewrite this as
the natural log of vb over va
divided by right instead of multiplying
it times this i can divide it by this
reciprocal v c
over v d
vd
so i just rewrote it i just did a little
bit of fraction math that's all i did
instead of multiplying it times this i
divided by its reciprocal
now
now you see why the previous video i did
was done
what is this equal to
in the previous video i showed you that
v b
over v a
is equal to v c over v d we did that big
convoluted hairy proof to prove this
and now that we proved it we can use
this to know that this quantity is equal
to this quantity so if you divide
something by itself they're equal to
each other this is equal to
one
if that's equal to one then what's the
natural log of one
so our change in our mystical s
state variable is n r times the natural
log of 1. what's the natural log of 1. e
to the what power is equal to 1. e to
the 0 is equal to 1.
n times r times 0. i don't care how big
or whatever this is zero so it equals
zero
so there we have it we've we've stumbled
upon a legitimate state variable that
deals with that deals with heat if we
define change in s
change in s
is equal to
the heat added to the system divided by
the temperature at which the heat was
added to the system this is a legitimate
state variable
now we we don't have much intuition
about what it really means at kind of a
micro a micro state level but at least
we've stumbled upon some property of
something wherever if s is 10 here if s
is 10 and we go and go around here our
change in s will be zero s is 10 again
if s is i don't know let's say s is 15
here and we go around some crazy cycle
we come back here our change in s is
going to be 0 again or sorry it's going
to be 15 again so we didn't have our
change in s will be 0. so our s itself
will be 15 again so s is a legitimate
state variable but we don't have a good
sense of what it actually means
of what it actually means we'll leave
that to a future video